I'm Henry I can't range my street I
didn't change my stream stuff so I'm
making my mods do it for me well you do
it yourself because I'm a bum oh yeah
because you got a I'm not gonna tell you
what the what I'm gonna tell you Oh
Oh is it flour bad that's a flower oh I
finished it
Oh what the I was like a replay of
everywhere we died okay wait I didn't I
don't know how to kill I don't think I
did
don't just stopping on my head killed me
why is there this skull oh that's
bad this gunk is coming for me do I ride
it help nope oh this climb okay alright
there's a gold coin yeah there sure is
mark go back for it
I'm trying there's two of them Jesus
Christ how do you how do you multiple
wall jump okay you think well I'm so
hard I can't climb so hard okay one of
us has to bounce the other up there you
want me to bounce you up there get up on
the wall above me and then I'll bounce
you I think I know how to get over there
but you guys keep trying that router you
do it all about
oh okay well now I see what you're doing
there mark and huh yeah you see what I'm
doing it's true what I think he it
possibly how'd you do that
oh don't touch that thing that thing's
very deadly I want you guys to get this
coin why are we trying for the coin like
the heist would need it okay oh there's
a flower on that thing - yeah yeah
see there's a flower whatever it's a
spiky
hello first you guys wait wait wait
Rhino dude your turn is it from the
higher one or the lower one no or what
you gotta like do it right off as far as
you can on the ledge and then jump
immediately what I did up there why are
we go under what for this coin I've been
asking oh alright I have a solution to
this right yeah what a quitter what is
happening get the coin next time you win
of course
excuse you you cut out your voice cut
out there I said lazy get the coin
that's a little rude you know there's a
family-friendly Channel why did I jump
into it would you have to save the skunk
where do we save the skunk why wouldn't
we what's the skunk do it hello I
understand now I didn't know their
spikes I'm sorry I'm sorry okay the
trick is you gotta let go and not jump
only at the bottom not at the top you
can do this I don't think this is
working
if you want to give it a try for
learnings sake yes what am I suppose to
do
you got it hey you save it I waited
but we're gonna get the coin we all
failed there was no coin wasn't that
coin on that one this coin here well
sorry sorry sorry don't you button oh
yeah I think there's some over here yeah
but if we had coin do something there's
[Laughter]
the door you stupid man you're right man
we could point oh we don't have a coin
you want to go back to the coin you
wanna go back for the point Oh we'd
unlocks an entirely different path oh
yeah I don't get it for us I don't know
what we're not overachievers where are
we going
there's a difference some changed yeah
we're underwater now no there was water
before they're like what a poor wait
come here come stand under me I'm up get
it get away I'm up do it I'm making it
guys how'd you get up that oh I'm making
it I don't know the mechanics of that
but that was very close yeah the fish
are always there way that's okay yeah
ha no no nope not gonna do hey bud oh
it's uh you got let yourself drop off a
little bit oh it's get a bullet one jump
you just afternoon
oh boy oh boy oh boy get the coin I did
it I got it it's not God on my screen
you believe me you believe me right
you believe me I got trust you you trust
me good you should my life at this game
is still broken I appreciate that
with such a thriving fanbase you'd think
that they wasn't Patchett so I have to
go back to four yeah we we get in there
[Applause]
okay okay all right let's unlock this
really fun thing and then give mark all
of our properties too much Oh God this
is not a place to go oh you it's
targeting oh wait okay so I need I'll be
here luring it no who's it targeted damn
it no no no no no it's targeting me oh
this goes up their targets us
work you practically doing this you stay
there let it let it settle let it settle
[Laughter]
all right I'll open the door you ready
okay
one of you guys need to get over there
mark right now we can make it can you
get off the button please my good man
yes no you go
oh boy okay wherever I go from here I
gotta go oh don't worry we got this oh
it just stays do I could write somehow
oh yeah I think I think another one how
this has to be up here nah hang on
hang on right now I got it I think yeah
yeah I don't know what do for you ah
nothing how high up you are can you make
the jump from there all the way to the
top damn it I'm curious if I can but I
don't know if it'd be good for me okay I
wouldn't be okay
mark jump over and see if you can get on
that grass platform right above me I
don't want you to laser to hug you right
now I don't want to so that's not a plan
damn it I don't understand these
hitboxes it is a leading away thing
that's that's what it's got to be
otherwise I found it
what so I did it maybe I have to run
away look this thing chase me in tag one
of yous at the beeline to beat it I
think yeah okay wait
yeah you have to die it'll come from me
and let me wait let me get in better
position okay it'll come from me and
then Bob you slide under their world
hide hide no yes yeah they're here I'm
gonna die no you're not definitely gonna
die it's fine wait I don't think we
agreed on the plan Granger's book slide
in there
did Bob leave his Bob guy
I think Bob's gone alright wait you know
how this works right wait I will let you
through just please just go up there
distract it I will go through do you
know I made it here we go
I got it okay it's now come for me the
door has been open for you okay all
right all right just hold on and be
smart I don't think this is gonna work
just for the record this can definitely
be solved by just two people we know
this he/she one what is that whoa
okay wait that we got to get the laser
to allow one of us to circumvent it on
this side so that we it is slide under
here and then jump up that's what it is
right yeah why did you distract from up
here I know what you alright I made a
tactical error yeah yeah you sure did we
did by deciding to play this game all
right
listen there's definitely a reason to
come up here that's that's a certainty
yeah oh yeah God all right this is it
there's a reason and it's it's a
distracting reason it is distracting
reason right so yeah if I'm okay by if I
I don't want to hear it I don't hear at
all
I don't want to hear it listen dude no I
got it yeah okay so I go up here yeah
right
if I'm up here and I duck it can't get
me yes right so I Bob - you need to die
and what's that gonna do for you it's
gonna then focus on me as the nearest
thing and then you can sprint to the
finish all right it's gonna focus on me
it's not gonna hit me it's not gonna hit
me it's not gonna hit me no way nohow
see Bob we're yet we know we don't need
it oh yeah that's right okay ha okay
wait okay you go under the under the
tower there all right get on well we
tested Bob's theory does it work
okay tested my theory doesn't work okay
[Laughter]
you get back to where you just were duck
down there I'm gonna get in front of it
and when it comes for me and when I die
that's when you go for it okay you hear
me what go back to where you just we're
height no it'll it'll kill you okay it's
certainly well okay you need to get
under get under this get under yeah get
under that and then I will know then
you'll be too far ahead anyway okay that
won't work either right there's where it
starts to go for me right yeah yeah it
sure do you move up one more segment
holy yeah all right Bob I figured
out if I'm up here it don't give me but
it's not far enough forward to make any
discernible difference so that far left
platform does that exist for any reason
that is shielded from everything we just
got to get someone underneath this thing
wait is it
wait is I remember out okay now there's
something that happens there and I don't
know what the reason for it is but I
think it has something to do with coming
back down there you see that thing well
have you stayed down on that platform
when I have you standing down on that
bottom platform oh wait I think I slide
down the middle no the what did you
watch do it mark slide down the middle
there and just stand there okay man you
tried dunking it's late to the right I
know I know have it I got it okay
everybody I've got it you have to trust
me right you have to trust me okay I can
do this
did I have to trust me I need you two to
die
I got it sound right here here we go
just just die yeah it'll be fine just
die die what about this hey what about
this solution Oh trust me Bob trust me
Bob just died yeah just died it's fine
okay then go go there and then I go and
I go and I slide and I go wow wow to the
right there to mark all right good
teamwork there guys so the whole
solution was don't play with friends
okay we solved it
good work team okay Sorry Sorry
oh that okay here we go
or what what triggered that ow what
triggered that thing I don't know I have
no idea what triggered that oh the skunk
press the button up top
nice how did you what you have to - not
jump what's the - button look X
sorry Bob
baby how the did you press the
button up there mark I did yeah it only
did the boulder hello that was the only
thing it did alright yeah oh you can -
off the legs yeah you can - anytime you
are oh yeah I'm a plant with the half
full deck that's real smart but we got
one of the crystals to help sonic with
I'm trying to dive and jump it's not
working Oh fish you douchebag oh
this point is there fall sex pointy ball
sacks okay this is the part where you
dive and you have to jump and then dive
Oh we not are we going for up top or
down low here probably down low yeah
it's gotta because there's no way that
no way that can I stand on this
pillar nope but I can stand on that was
this do whoa what do I do
underwater passage alright hey yeah we
go for that way
don't worry I'll go for that how did you
thread that needle where's the top of
that oh sorry sorry sorry works it's
oh yeah it's impossible - jump across
the ton it's stupid do you want to I'm
gonna be able to recreate that dive I
magically did yeah all right oh god I
can't figure this out like there okay I
think I did it
oh just points everywhere I
can't get in down here no I did really
there's a wall there
oh okay oh God how yeah there you gotta
fall off in an air jump I'm in love with
- I can't not - okay we're holy mr.
Pfister you guys see this mr. Pfister
right there yeah it's okay don't worry
about him
was there a keyhole we saw somewhere
like now it was probably the bridge
thing that was all it was okay but
there's a level below us right now there
is how do you see I don't see it there's
like a little island down that with a
lock on it I can see like map maybe it's
cuz I'm
I don't know maybe it's junkies gonna go
focus I know look at skunky look how
good how is it what is it what you just
do I did the thing oh boy oh god damn it
I'm down here Bob press that button I
think it's a cannon to fire directly
into my brain just button there's a
button I'm down get up there press that
button five
if you could please figure this out
that'd be amazing wait how did you get
up top mark another stand I doing the
dash jump thing that you did I'm here
now wait can you make it
just do it
wait it's fine I definitely won't kill
you again okay all right I'm gonna
believe you I choose to believe there's
a limited amount of time to get through
this section wait it's not my fault
[Laughter]
it's skill-building if you don't build
the skills you won't you won't be able
to keep up in the later levels very
timed it's fun I had nothing to do with
that come on now you freaking me out
it's your fault No
you're just walking into now come
on I've tried to see I'm trying to see
how close I could be to it without
actually touching it look I gotta go
okay this you gotta end this right now
go it's all mine
you guys my second try it wasn't
that hard yeah I'm having a rough time
anyway I do actually have to go oh all
right well that was funny
I'm not done what I mean you guys can
continue doing that I just I just
actually have to leave early well
farewell Bob have a good night everybody
thank you enjoy playing this game some
more with oh dude you're officially
doing this to yourself now see you later
guys thank you see you it's just a
tiniest little wait where's the exit
wait wait look we'll drop directly below
you drop straight down see what is that
on the left
nothing okay now be careful there are
arrows we put a coin in honey we don't
have a board why don't we have a coin no
we didn't get another coin yeah we did
get another point do I have it does that
mean that I have it I'm coming
yeah I'm dead I did have it oh no that
was not ideal okay there's a way you can
drop down from the far right right
I think you might need to drop down from
the far right do you see the light I
don't think that's a drop egapp maybe
not I'm going for I guarantee you that's
not a gap we'll find out I made it
well it's all I made it this time look
at me
yeah I see you I see that I see that
nice to you I was about to duck in
everything man
yeah I believe you I believe that and I
believe you all right let's just do what
this unlocked and then we'll call it
there yeah unlock levels are a lot
easier to make you look good call
look man look oh oh hey this looks fun
okay sorry I don't mean to do these
things don't listen revenge is not you
don't need revenge revenge is not okay
no you told me if I go down wait if we
go if I go on on fours you can bounce on
me all right this has no practical use I
just thought it was fascinating I'm
going there I go I'm safe here
all right cool this button do oh oh it's
not just the best god damn it
look it's not on purpose it's not on
purpose where's this go it's a secret no
this is not a secret okay
tough crowd okay okay okay all right
okay I'm safe here there's something
below me am I supposed to ride on this
thing there you go where the fish just
came up from yeah you go why are you
laying up for me to do the thing nothing
I can't get back I can't get back you
got to do it for me man okay
okay how are you alive slide I don't
know you got a slide I think you can go
in I'll find out yeah just fist
me and there we go a better alternative
is oh I'm gonna try riding on one of
these bad boys
oh I can ride on one of these bad boys
dude for how we get the button how we
get the button whoo
I did it okay uh I'm not sure what this
is doing okay dude I did it what about
the second button I don't know what the
second button does all I know is that
I'm going down here nevermind I'm making
progress I'm very good at this I got a
lot of training from playing uh I want
to be the guy to completion which was a
slog but yeah I forgot about the fist
okay I got this you slide see what does
it do okay what did this do it open the
Middle where Oh hit that button hit one
button above you it opened up the open
the middle to a button the one up here
yeah sorry
okay okay clunk okay oh no wait this
button was always here never mind
I'm sorry I'm sorry that I just make
this easier to get back to here um maybe
oh oh god damn it
that's a sprint there right what sorry
kill me sorry oh yeah act like you're
done to be a thousand goddamn time
listen I highly doubt it was a full foul
Zend okay here we go here we go here we
go here we go here we go
ahh why how do you make this jump right
here you just got to go for it man like
that gonna ride the balls yeah then go
up God just go up and you made you made
it get the gem get the gem oh wait
listen man I'm giving it my I'm gonna
get this dude
it's broken you don't sprint out that
you just follow ah Rick yes I just fall
we're right at the end man oh I was
there on the balls good well uh on my
screen it was something very different
but you got this I believe in you I'm
just coming as a contingency backup I
know you've got this got it I believe in
you I feel like something horrible
happens here you're good okay all right
guys I got a Jim one you did it you did
it you did it you did it you did it I'm
proud of you I'm proud of you
wait didn't we beat nine wait yeah what
the hell oh we went through the secret
path on nine oh that's right maybe we
should finish out this section all right
yeah you talked me into it I can make no
trouble watch this I'm gonna beat you
there you write ah you're right
I know there we go easy this game is
easy why don't we why don't we make it
so hard all Oh dad once yeah exactly
easy peasy I still there's still a
secret level all we needed a coin from
sidon wait no no we got the coins we got
all the coins because it says palm tree
Islands two of two why is there an extra
level down below there there was one if
we go back up to six that was a
different exit all the upper path yeah I
bet I can get up there yeah I can get up
there with my super jumps I've got some
mad hops watch this okay it should
be what this should be working what it's
not oh wait I think I know I think I
know what the deal is because there's
like a moment when you glow there we go
whoa how'd you do that I just missed it
it's some you got to wait for the apex
of your jump you got to jump at your
very peak that's the only time that you
can super that's it
close okay and you just got to do that
twice in row
in order to get over there did you jump
again adduce gets drop jump glow hit -
like that yeah there we go
yeah it's that's a long jump
oh how that's impossible
how would anybody do that if you don't
want to get up there that way I didn't
open the gates back to that side easily
it's fine
where are you oh ho you can get up there
that easily oh yeah Oh straight tell you
there's another way to get up there a
little bit easier alright don't know if
that jump is possible I still can't
figure how to do that you see oh yeah
you glow red oh yeah that's when you saw
at that time yeah that's when you can -
and that's what you tableau right as
well no I glow blue so you - first then
jump yeah no you drop jump - oh that's
what it is drop jump - god damn it I
might have made that one nope
oh I almost went through who are you
sure did come on why'd you die instead
of just going back up dude I just this
is the only way I know how to do this
I'm gonna do it this way because this is
the way I know it's just who I am right
here there's a thing it's Who I am
see it's Who I am that's very let's just
finish this out last one who tried yeah
all right spooky boys over there chillin
by a button he's doing something he's
polishing something okay those are bad
even though they look like they why Oh
Oh dad do what is that I don't oh oh
that I punch the button
all right god um you got it buddy you
all know you got it buddy pal okay okay
um hit me here huh hit me where oh yeah
the barrel is not indestructible good
for you
there's something here he's breaking it
good work
you can you can me you won't oh yeah
yeah man we're done go home don't
lizards are the splats oh wait I got a
button to shoot oh so we gotta line this
Canada oh there you go
yeah I miss nicely done Judy's hand I
think we hit the little purple thing oh
I can get on his hand oh wait hang on
I'll send it back I thought I just died
listen listen listen buddy friend my
upper side okay that's not yeah he's mad
okay no geez send it back man
[Applause]
he's mad okay watch this I'm up I'm
up I'm up oh if you touch it you
die alright send her back baby
oh yeah there we go he's dead Wow
that's all I wouldn't be we just killed
like a god of the forest I don't know if
that's a good thing
well alright oh okay
good job wait that was good work we
figured it out pretty quick there yeah
we're smart okay how is there this boss
fight and then level 6 with that
I don't know I think it's just
I don't know I don't know man maybe
there's some superpower up where I can
so they're all a secret
I thought we found I can just pilot us
to this other Island I don't want to go
I don't want to do it I'm done I'm good
no thank you no thank you you mean no no
this level no the last part of this
level are you want to do this and you
want to first tribe
why that was not ground apparently oh I
don't know what you're doing but I love
it oh I put another crystal how it kills
you did you know that yeah sure did
buddy Oh stupid oh it's still killed you
oh this way it says this way well
there's a button did you press the
button yeah it didn't do anything all
right
it lowered the door that you can get out
what is that oh you unlocked that I'm
good I'm done thank you
I'm done welcome bonus level bye no I've
done I'm leaving I'm gone all right see
no bump um wait one more No
[Music]